JENNY BROWN: Happy
2022, everyone.
It's so good to be back.
Today, we're talking
about starting your year
with free cloud education,
more inclusive hybrid
meetings, and the
eight megatrends
that we're looking at to
improve cloud security
and cloud adoption.
I'm Jenny Brown, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
If one of your resolutions
was to grow your cloud skills,
you're in luck.
We've compiled a list of
free learning opportunities
for you to kick off your
year with education,
from free access to Cloud Skills
Boost to half-day trainings
on cloud fundamentals.
Go to the blog for the full
list, dates, and to sign up.
As we enter 2022, it's
clear that adjusting
to ambiguity and remote
work is critical to success.
Google Meet spent much
of 2021 adding features
and functionality to Workspace
to support a hybrid team,
from backgrounds to
noise cancellation.
Google also spent
much of last year
developing our
own best practices
as a team for making hybrid
meetings as inclusive
as possible to further improve
that hybrid work experience.
Check out the blog
for more details
on how to make the
most of your meetings.
At Google Cloud, we
prioritize security by design
and work continuously to deliver
secure products and customer
controls.
Additionally, we take advantage
of industry megatrends
that increase cloud
security further,
outpacing the security of
on-prem infrastructure.
IT decision makers should
pay close attention
to these megatrends,
because they're
not just transient issues to be
ignored once 2023 rolls around.
They guide the development of
cloud security and technology,
and will continue to do so
for the foreseeable future.
Head to the blog for the
full list and a deep dive.
If you want to read more about
any of these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.